hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game between Anatoly Karpov
and Boris Spassky I was played in 1982
it was the feed a World Cup the finals
and these are the tiebreaks
the first game between Karpov and
Spassky ended in a draw this is game
number two where Karpov has the white
pieces and it's as it is a tie-break it
is a fifth 15 minutes each game with no
increment so it can last only half an
hour
now before we check out this very
interesting game we don't have a nice
photo challenge so best of luck to
everyone who is the gentleman in the
photo here there you have it and you get
extra points if you can name both of the
cats okay if you can name only one cat
that's I guess also a point but it would
be better if you could name both cats so
that being said let's check out this
game and what had a Spassky all worked
up after the game so Karpov opens with E
for we have a d6 the pity defense d4 g6
Knight to c3 and brush-up to g7 nice to
f3 Knight to d7 by Spassky under now
Bishop to e2 as possibly goes east 6 we
have castles and knights to e7 now
Bishop to g5
bye-bye Karpov and here as Pascal goes
for H 6 H 6 a very interesting move
because it questions Karpov
Bishop and g5 forcing it back but also
Carper plays Bishop to e3 creates a nice
target for Karpov later later
for example if Spassky castles Queens
King side then Queen to d2 will create a
very nice target on H on h6 so here
Spassky plays another very injuries a
very interesting move he goes b6 so
already creating some targets on the
king size now he he says he says that
you know he has plenty of time and he
can take a moment to think at the light
square Bishop as well and here a carpet
took a lot of time it's a 15-minute game
so also in game number one he spent like
eight minutes eight minutes on one move
and here also he spent some four minutes
I believe I will put
there is a video footage of this entire
event on YouTube so I will put a link in
the description below so you can watch
the whole thing oh okay
Bishop to b7 prepared by Spassky and the
now Karpov goes a for preparing to push
a5 and create weaknesses on the
queenside a5 by Spassky he doesn't
follow it
Queen to d2 now if Spassky would Castle
then h6 would definitely be a problem
push up to b7 and now a couple goes nice
to e one nice thing you want he wants to
push f3 to really solidify d4 pawn and
then later in the future Knight to b3 to
f4 will be an idea
Spassky goes f5 immediately piling up on
that efore pawn and after again after
some consideration
Karpov did play f3 although even here he
took some minute and a half
although the commentators were very
confused why Carper was spending so much
time on this F to remove Knight to f6
we have Bishop to b5 check asking
Spassky what what does he want to do
here does he want to push c6 and then
carpet will simply push the bishop back
but then it's possible no longer if for
example c6 is played here you will have
to move the bishop and then it's not all
that likely that you will Castle
queenside so you know you push the pawns
on the King side you push the pawns on
the Queen side higher King will pretty
much have to stay in the center or maybe
even king f7 will be an idea but okay
Bishop to b5 would check Bishop to c6
now Spassky offers an exchange of
bishops Bishop captures this comes with
Czech Knight captures and now v5e
capture Sun d5 Knight captures on d5 and
here we have Knight to e7 by Spassky or
capturing on d5 was also an idea for
example Knight captures a captures and
now Knight to e5 but then c3 is coming
and white white will have a very
pleasant game here so instead after
Knight captures on d5 Knight to e7 was
an attempt and here Karpov has a plenty
of good plans he could play Knight
captures here and after Bishop captures
either capture on h6 immediately but
this will
capturing the point on b2 or he could
simply or he could play something like
c3 but then black could simply push
Queen d7 castles Queen side bring the
other rook over to the Kings side and
then black will would even offer the
point here just open up the H file
another idea after this Knight to e7
move by Spassky his knife captures on e7
and then after Queen captures he
captures an f5 G captures on f5 and then
bringing the night over to d3 where
Knight will be able to come to to f4
rook can come to e1 nice to night here
night here will be an idea although this
would all be fine for white Karpov has a
different idea so after 97 he simply
plays c4 and you know if Spassky wants
to release the tension then a Karpov
will simply increase his presence in the
center of the board and if either of the
pawns capture on d5 then he will control
C 6 and ecigs and the Karpov would enjoy
this very much so King to f7 by Spassky
also possible with something like Knight
captures here but then like we said he
captures on d5 Knight goes here with
preparation of 95 but then carpals
Knight can can go something like ninety
to ninety d4 and then go all the way to
c6 or or e6 probably after a night c2 to
d4 Spassky will have to give up the
darks for Gosha PEs you don't want to
allow this night to come to e6 so
instead of all of this King to f7 was
played by Spassky and now finally a
couple moves the knight from e1 knighted
III preparing to go to f4 we have Queen
to d7 and here
Karpov could play Knight captures on e7
it's a very interesting line King
captures on e7 or Queen captures and
then pawn captures here and rook e1 will
be a very nice attack for White King
captures and then e 5 and now of course
if you capture then you get a nice
captors here Queen captures Bishop
captures and now you have this
sufficient hook or an in-between move
Knight captures on g6
sorry about that first Knight captures
on g6 and then after black reacts this
reiax you cannot go king f7 to attack
the knight because then Knight captures
rook with chicks so here you would have
to move the King and only now does white
capture back rug d8 you move the bishop
bishop before and white would enjoy his
extra pawn so Karpov did not go for this
rather he played Knight captures on f6
he has his plane and he keeps to it
we have Bishop captures and here comes
Bishop captures on h6 simply grabbing a
pawn here was a very nice moment where
probably a player like a Michael tal
would go for something like e v which
would create some create a very nice
attack for white for example if you push
e 5 of course you don't want to allow
the captures because now Knight captures
here
I checked the checks the King forms the
Queen if you don't want to lose the
Queen you have to capture the knight
button you're losing the Queen either
way so after this if I move you would
have to play push up here and then rook
F 2 e1 is coming and white will enjoy
again a very nice attack but Karpov
doesn't want anything to do with this
instead he simply grabs BH bond which
seems kind of dangerous because you know
you're opening the H file here as
possible really has a rockand on h6 but
corp of says that this is completely
fine Knight to c6 by Spassky route 81
and here we have rook 88 we have Bishop
to g5 and here Bishop the d4 check is
played you could play something like
King to h1 there are no there are no
tricks here for example even if you're
flicking to h1 moves like rook captures
don't really work you can simply capture
and if the other book comes here King to
g3 will escape nicely and there there
are no good ways for black to actually
continue this attack although it seems
very scary the bishop is guarding F
during g1 the rook is controlling the
entire H file but there is no good way
to continue this attack after we try to
open some files lines and then Queen to
f4 check is coming and then white is on
the attack so after this Bishop to d4
check even though you could move the
King it's a it's a rapid game you don't
want to allow moves like rook captures
on h2
when the Phaedo
cup title is on the line so Bishop to e3
a Karpov offers to trade bishops and now
Queen to east sex by Spassky after
giving the position some consideration
Bishop captures Knight captures and now
Knight to f4 finally the knight comes
into a for inviting Spassky to capture
on c4 but then it will be very hard to
defend it the knight on d4 but again
after some consideration Spassky decides
to capture it he decides that this is
alright as Karpov immediately goes rock
to c1 the move that refutes a spassky's
idea we have Queen captures on a4 and
now comes of course rook captures on c7
would check so this is a the critical
moment but it doesn't really matter
because here as Pascal played rook to e7
and this was the moment where the
commentators were like whoa Spassky
touched the rook he now has to play with
the rook so he did of course I have to
play it
rook to e7 was played and this is of
course the idea he missed rook captures
any 17 captures and Knight captures and
g6 would check King has to move and then
Karpov simply grabs a free rook on h8
and ok I don't think he was very upset
about this but even without after this
rook captures on c7 it doesn't matter
that he blundered the rook whatever he
plays here it's it's a game over so even
if something like King to g8 is played
you can go King to g8 simply moving the
king then Knight the d5 is coming
threatening to jump to f6 and there's a
very little you can do here rock to e6
Queen g5 is coming the queen is coming
now with the threat of Queen to d8 and
this will be this will be checkmate
after after a couple of moves so after
Queen blocks now comes Knight here with
check and now you have to give up the
Queen or it doesn't matter even if you
give up the rook you will still not
enjoy this very much rook captures now
the Queen has to move for example
Queen f8 and then you you're getting
checkmated the king has nowhere to go
Queen blocks Queen captures checkmate
but yeah this is the the epic moment
rock c7 check Spassky blocked
seven captures captures and here in 96
check was played the moves boskie missed
and it was all over and like I said
there is a complete footage of this
event so I will put a link in the
description below it will be the first
thing you will see in the description so
feel free to check it out I think the
video is some half an hour long but for
those of you who don't have half an hour
I did prepare for you here it is the
moment where spots can you light the
cigarette ornament ass so he just
wondered car pool table very self but
yeah you're playing Karpov is black I
could never have it but he did make it
to the finals of the feeder World Cup
and you know he did draw the first game
against Karpov and then he lost the
second one but it you know Karpov was a
beast in those days as he was the
reigning world champion and he did have
the white pieces so but a very
interesting him I do hope you enjoyed it
and yeah this is something to take a
break from the Fischer series but as of
tomorrow we are continuing our favorite
series with the first candidate match of
1971 so you know I I do hope you will
enjoy that as well so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check too on my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon with the before-mentioned
content season